wir haben heute mein natel im bild
veröffentlicht was ist der anlass für
diesen appell viele fachärzte viele
hausärzte berichten uns dass deutlich
weniger patienten auch die chronisch
kranken patienten zu ihm in die praxen
kommen die notaufnahmen den
krankenhäusern berichten dass die zahl
der patienten mit schlaganfällen mit
herzinfarkten stark zurückgegangen ist
und mich treibt sehr um mich besorgt
dass viele patienten im moment nicht zu
ihrem arzt gehen nicht in die praxen in
die krankenhäuser gehen aus sorge um
eine krone infektion und ich möchte
einfach den appell deutlich machen bitte
gehen sie zum arzt chronisch kranke
brauchen den regelmäßigen kontakt zum
arzt jemand der akut krank ist muss
natürlich auch den arzt sehen
mittlerweile ist das infektionsrisiko in
den arztpraxen so minimiert dass man da
auch beruhigt hingehen kann
wie dramatisch ist die situation sowie
die ärzte schildert wie groß ist das
risiko dadurch entstehen für patienten
mit chronischen erkrankung ist die
regelmäßige untersuchung der regelmäßige
kontakt zum arzt auch wichtig um zu
schauen ist der verlauf der erkrankung
um frühzeitig auch einen schlechteren
verlauf zu erkennen also aus ist aus
vorsorgegründen aus gesundheitsgründen
sehr sehr wichtig und gerade auch bei
akuten problemen insbesondere auch wenn
es richtung herzproblemen zum beispiel
geht es natürlich sehr sehr wichtig
frühzeitig einen arzt zu kontaktieren
und da darf die sorge vor einer
möglichen infektion nicht dann die akute
not überlagern und deswegen möchte ich
die patienten einfach bitten und ja auch
auffordern für die eigene gesundheit
bitte gehen sie zum arzt
wir nähern uns der veröffentlichung
corona app gesundheit wie immer sie
heißen wird was ist zu erwarten
besser ist es steht ziel ist dass wir
mitte juni eine app haben die freiwillig
ist die dezentral sammelt sozusagen die
kontakte anonymisiert die ich hatte dass
wir hier zum beispiel in einer gewissen
zeit in einer gewissen nähe zueinander
waren über bluetooth gemessen und in dem
fall dass jemand positiv getestet wird
kann er oder sie daneben ist hat noch
einmal dann anonym
die anderen informieren dass sie
vielleicht besser sich mal testen lassen
auf jeden fall aber die nächsten zwei
wochen ihre kontakte reduzieren wie
sicher kann der nutzer sein dass die
daten nicht für andere zwecke
missbraucht wird
jeder kann sich sehr sicher sein dass
die daten nur für den genau angegebenen
zweck genutzt werden der
datenschutzbeauftragte ist von anfang an
mit eingebunden
auch das bundesamt für sicherheit in der
informationstechnologie ist von anfang
an mit eingebunden
es geht um datenschutz wer hat zugriff
und wert keinen zugriff und um
datensicherheit dass die app auch nicht
gehackt werden kann und beides ist auf
höchstem niveau sichergestellt
juli steht wir tun alles dafür dass wir
mitte juni mit dieser app starten kann